>>KIEW H
SEIZED FROM S LAGO.COVERED LIST
PA IOCUMENTS TT PE TONIL FROA A
REFERENC CANTE FORPECIAL
HELOSS., A PERSON WHO HA
EVAN PEREZ IS OUT
EVAN, WHATU TELL US
DE INADVERTENTLY UST FINDING O T
PUBLIC.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT MAY HAV
POSTED THEOURTOCT
INADVERT NO
LONGERABLE.
G NEWS UNCOVERED IT AND D THE
THIS IS HOW THAT
E TACU
IN ADDITIO TLTHCARE
INFORMATION THAT WE PREVLY THAJ
AGE PGA AND  SETENNT, A
TRT WAS IN THESE
AC PRESIDE'S
RESIGNATION FRRS GUILD.
THESE ARE ALL OF COURS
BELIEVED WERE PERSONAL D
AND IT REALLY, WHAT IT SORT OF
SHOWS IS THAT THE FBI DID HAVE M
BEAIN D BE
ER
THAT IT W A
SYSTEM THAWARKING.
DOCUME ALS YOU
CITAY THEY WERE ED UTHH COULD
THIS M IHO
DND KIM JONG UN LETTERS.
THRIGHT?
I WANT TO GO NOW TFOLAMATI
WHITE HOUSE LAWY
THE FACTT THE FBI OI.E Y
SHOULDD WHAT THEY OU
NOT.
ISLAWYERS
T EMER
THE SPECIAL MASTERS TO THECL
KNOW THELSD AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
BUNK THIS COULD
CKFIORRUO I THINGRATULATIONSONY
KAITLAEVANRE
I THINK TH LETE THE SUJU MADE.W.
AS EVAN POINTED OUT, THETI
TRUMP WILL POINT OUT IS HO WHATE
THEM TW COULD THEY FAR
AF, THT IT
TLY FILED AGAI
TCEWH
SUPPOSED TO BERET.HIOMHI
BOIDN THIS.I THE 11thT LEINCTIC.
NKLE LIKMYHINK IT
COULD JUSTE
EYD TOE ON
L ISSUE
T REAL REQUIRE MUCH OPPOSED  TA
THAT THIS RE
OVERNMGRLLY ACTUALLY ONL
HE
MATTER OF TEYS
SO I THINK YOU CANCH THESE THIN.
BUT I DO THINK TOF GOIE SUPREME
WILL WASTE AD GETTING E I SU
THE NDECIDED AMERICANSI THINK II
WITH.I LEAV
>> AND OBVIOUSLY IT
THAT ALL OF IT WAS SOMF
ANEM TDETHIS.
YOU ARE N ELYEIR ASON TO BE
SUS AT
T
NEAROR,
YOPU I TO THE P
D HIS
AND  DRAMATICALLY OL DYNAMICS TF
SO IPO
S THINKINGNI HGO
AND SHE SAIDE THINKS HE'HIMSEL
I WANTED TO  IR E CEASES TO  RYT
RUT FUNDRAIS
WAY HE DID
E PART
BRANDING.
HE'S UNDER ITHIS A WAY TO CALL E
IOA HUNT.
THHEART IS IORN' EAGER A
D  DHE OR  HE'S
PARTICULARLYD EXPERIENCETY, AT
>> SWITH
K YOU'RE SEE A
POINT INIF
YSHE FLAME AND HIS
RESTRAIN
HIMSELF FROM ATTENTI ISRT
CONFLICT A LIS
N  HIS PL
I  I
EITHER.LD BTED IF
HE COULD FINICATE WHO WOULD ASSM
THE
LEGACY THAT HEE THEM
I SEE HE'SING TO KNOCKN  THEORYA
T P'BUT I THINK TRUMD LIKE TO
O HES THIS
IS MY CAIDUR POINT HE HA WITDeSN
GHT, THANK YOU VER